einen weiteren teil meiner piero der
epischen legende und wir sind heute in
einer wunderbaren kleinen gruppe
unterwegs und zwar was für kleine gruppe
wir sind zwei technische probleme welche
probleme was laberst du ja hast du hörst
mich ich dachte sich die probleme
was laberst du kleine gruppe dieses geld
flösse ja der leute ist ein paar und
keine gruppe kleine gruppe sagt klein
oha was hier für geile stückchen sind
alter diesen guck dir das mal an ich
weiß jetzt dass ich bin gerade bei
koordinaten 10.000 5000 ja ich wollte es
erst mal kurz die königin hier begrüßen
knicks trinken
also geht doch schon offiziell
akzeptiert das finde ich sehr sehr geil
es tut mir jetzt schon im voraus leid
wenn ich irgendwie meine stimme sich
anhört ich hab nämlich seit heute morgen
bin ich einfach krank aus dem nichts wie
willst du hals und ohren schmerzen und
ich habe mir jetzt tabletten gekauft er
war mein kompletten hals betäuben
davon hat ja auch gesagt hypothek nur
vier stück am tag essen deswegen ist
alles schön bezeugt ich fühle nichts und
es schwingt wie ganz klar ich habe extra
gesagt ich muss wir reden ja gut er bei
mir ist es zurzeit so etwas war was mein
plan ist also krank bin ich nicht aber
mein plan ist einfach jetzt das haus zu
bauen und zwar in dem stil ihr seht es
schon hier der sommer da dir die stadt
hause ein bisschen gebaut hat er auch
gezeigt da wo ich aufgenommen wurde zum
bauch da gerade auf dem server war das
hier ist die stadtmauer in dem stil wird
dann unsere stadt wahrscheinlich werden
das hatten auch glaube ich keine stadt
oder rea genau abel und auch dieses
andere
sie halten glaube ich auch noch keine
solche stil er verrät erst mal halb also
ich bin vielleicht bei der stadt pink
ist das ganz geile wir haben das jetzt
mit w wie abgeklärt als er gehört
definitiv nicht mehr zu statt blau
das möchte ich sagen ich meine er hat
die stadt blau aus eigenem antrieb
verlassen
sozusagen eine art hochverrat wenn er
das meine das hätte ohne konsequenzen
bleiben könnt ist es aber in dem fall
nicht und deswegen ja sinnlos blockiert
in der stadt
ja und ich finde das ist auch eigentlich
die richtige entscheidung wenn sich
irgendwann beschwert oder rewe oder so
dass dass das irgendwie unfair sei oder
irgendwie sowas ist es einfach komplett
ich finde wir haben komplett richtig
gehandelt hat ja selbst entschieden also
ich meine da haben wir ja nichts mit
bild er hat doch gesagt er will gehen
und wenn das achtel wir gehen also ja
sie folgte zu optimieren dass das
überlegen bei uns dann gegangen also ob
wir uns ist ja genau wir müssen uns
deshalb überlegen ob wir das halt wollen
deswegen erstmal wenn wir die zuschauer
jetzt frage ist es natürlich eigentlich
ein entscheid von unserer königin ja
genauso einfach die könige und
königinnen entscheidet demokratisch wie
unsere stadt aus haben will weil das
eine gute königin ist ja genau und ich
meine was gibt's an nicht zu verstehen
das ist eindeutig ja genau 1
ein paar leute verstehen hat einfach
unsere königin nicht und das ist halt
einfach so
wir müssen regeln zu enterprise also
carlos hat mir falsche koordinaten
gemüter verpacken
ehrlich ich bin jetzt bei koordinate
13.000 4300 extra hingeflogen und hier
ist ein scheiß wieso fliegst überhaupt
dahin weil er keineswegs als stadt pink
ach da statt pink und ich wollte ein
portal zur stadt pink machen also ich
weiss es den heute video hochgeladen hat
wurde in die weinstadt pink erwartet
kolja koordinaten bartels parallel an
das haus boiler ist letzten sekunde
übels geile folge camp ist krank und
welche anderen videos beim hörer nehmen
januar videos sind ich bin produktiv ich
baugebiets haus weiter ab und werde dann
auch endlich meinen umzug masern
bisschen
nehmen weil ich trumpfte ja schon was
heißt rumpf ich sag ja schon ich mich
unterhalte einmal so ein bisschen
während du hier
ich würde ja die folge ist dass bei
denen ein der spione minimap das ist
geil dann guck mal wie gehabt weil sie
nicht bestimmt irgendwann bestimmt
minimap an
aber eigentlich müsste die das pils biom
direkten an ihr von statt rot sein
glaube ich ja da war ich auch gewesen
aber das ist offenbar doch nicht keine
ahnung also übrigens wenn ihr jetzt
irgendwie meckert hier so hakan idee von
regina palace hotel wie mancher folgend
blabla klar nein ich nehme ich doch wie
weit die alpine nein in der hisense halt
besser wenn zeit
ob all das hat unsere königin
entschieden als wenn ihr jetzt meint
hier mit der entscheidung da bin ich
nicht einverstanden dass der contractor
das ja alles auffällt dann meckern
unsere königin an die hat nämlich hat
den youtube kanal ist geplant schoko
bukoba bei youtube kanal 1000 prozentig
für die schweren so ich werde mein haus
jetzt nämlich auch in dem stil bauen wie
es diese stadt hier ist ordnung dass ich
gleich sehe da kaum irgendwo muss jetzt
zunächst 1 endlich auch noch was
soziales hier mensch da sie passen
entwicklung hier mit mit der königin zu
kuba bekommt die soziale sozialisation
hier terraforming und irgendwie wird
normalerweise ich gucke sehr ungerne
gerade hier rein muss ich sagen ich mach
das jetzt nicht gerne auch wegen des
videos aber ich bin jetzt extra 10.000
blöcke weit geflogen und wird hier schon
keine portal für verschwenden
deswegen ist das irgendwie ja klar ich
finde dass die zuschauer einfach
legitimiere heißt das aha das war schon
immer man sucht weil die hängen ganze
zeit bei der stadt an dem an gesetzliche
dann nicht wurst aber total in wort
fehler mit fanny einfachsten wörter
wieder nicht ein heute weißt du hast
einen corner fortune
es ist aus köln auf fortune ich sehe
komm komm ja wohl 13.200 jetzt habe ich
13.200 ja ich finde ja das war schon
richtig war 100 weit weg die rabatten
der stadt baby alle so was wie bei euch
denn jetzt die kurve das ist schon eine
andere insel deswegen bei euch hier
jetzt einfach so eine art portaltüren
macht ihr aber nicht direkt dahin macht
die irgendwo versteckt naja also die
zuschauer werden auch nichts verraten
denke ich mache diesen breiten bilanz
von weiter weg also die haben es dieser
so ein pilz bio
das hat er eine große insel auf der sind
die und es hat dann noch zwei kleine
inseln und die zwei kleinen gern ja
eigentlich nicht mehr zur stadt den kann
ich darauf dann den cdm was ich in
dieser folge ich noch schaffen wollen
würde werde tun
dieses haus müssen auch noch aber als er
das gehört bei uns wahrscheinlich ich
bin gleich da ich als jetzt wo ich hier
bin kann ich mich auch teleportieren das
ist kein thema ja du musst mir gleich
einfach ganz groß helfen und zeigen was
ich abreißen lassen bereits schoko auf
folgen setzen genau nicht dass es damit
es mir auch volk wenn ich die tief
dimension g und jetzt habe ich mein
altes tokio verloren
wo ich hab ja kein skin drin also jetzt
ein portal in stat pink crazy wenn da
alle meine leute was kommt das kommt die
musik mitte bewegen
sag mir mal hilft mit beim hilfe immer
mit beiden beinen abreißen hier von
lewis haus und was ich dich fragen
wollte sollen wir das hier auch abreißen
sodass hier ja das ist hässlich sein mal
vorher den bildschirm ist vorbehalten
sei meist mal irgendwo ein item bleibt
mal ein paar blöcke von mir wegschmeißen
item vor dich einfach und gehe dann weg
ja und jetzt guckt mich an ob ich den
ausgemacht ich hab kein platz frei ok
moment warte marke playstation drauflos
nein was passiert jetzt garantiert ganz
im moment ich komme heute kämpfer recht
dass man halt aber ich bin immer war
zwei folgen auftrag über fünf blöcke
kommt er zu hin die firma genäht oder
man muss den kölner fortune machen der
ist nicht mehr schwer zu kräften bosco
bamberg coburg malabo hatten und es
platzt
das ist vielleicht noch mal zurück in
krieg die menschen ja ich stehe immer
noch da steht ja immer noch viele folgen
neu machen also was ich halt für ein
problem hatte war das mal ein turbo ich
hatte halt sonst so ich habe halt eine
kiste voll mit den spiegeln einen
rucksack
das gehalt bei weg war als ich mich dann
teleportiert habe wie hast du auf dem
draufgesetzt und an die spiegel benutzt
ach so ja nee ich hab das ja schon auf
den weg gemacht also eigentlich müsste
das gehen
ich will mich nicht zu mir passt ich
habe doch gemacht hat sollen wir folgen
folge mehr wie unnötig regiert seine
ganzen scheiß schoko petit hast du töne
des bücherregals scheiße aus wie hast du
dies konnten fällt gemacht eigentlich
welches konnten fällt die scott anfällt
moment war ich komplett bauchrolle fällt
hier kann ich meine hände revier
irgendwann mal wieder kommt wird er 100
prozentig unser baum pflücker
baumwollpflücker
das hier ist unser baumwoll flugfeld da
kann man nämlich im seite draus machen
und aus seide kann man sich prügeln und
zu kräften und obwohl genau aber ich
meine ich habe es gehört allerdings teil
gedacht an die schmiede soja ja gut ich
mache jetzt hier einfach mal überall
ich möchte auch mal bald an laternen
einfach machen dann können wir diesen
diesen einer welcher noch mal ein
bisschen anders regel sämtliches heißt
und das irgendwie hässlich
ja das ist auch herzlich deswegen hier
will ich werde hier auch aussehen also
du wirst deinen teil ableisten aber
machen wir das nämlich dann später
gerade das glaub ich ganz geil
ja es war hands eine augenweide aber ich
werde hier hinziehende du musst als dann
auch noch ein bisschen mehr so in den in
den stadtkern anbauen
also ich glaube mein haus lasse ich so
stehen aber komplett also recht findet
von der position her weiß ich jetzt
schon so eingebürgert ja klar von der
position her ist er ist sie aber vom
stil her vielleicht ein bisschen die
blöcke müssen austauschen weil wir
natürlich jetzt als stadt stil dieses
marbles plus mit mäßiger haben ja cool
wenn du dich dann aber auch anpasst
chocobos eigentlich dann auch nochmal
unsere königin muss eigentlich auch noch
mal ein sonnenstrahl dann aus diesem
anderen materialen bekommen oder was
sagst du zu kuba bobo das ist das
städtische pink ich habe auch folgen
geklickt mit der show coupe die das hat
letztes mal auf von goethe habe ich mich
erschrocken ich bin einfach vom blog
runtergefallen
aber ich habe im chaos was versprochen
und zwar dass ich ihm total mache und
ich kann ihm nur ein pott also von der
friedensstadt also von der mitte aus
mich doch der erste wert über dem portal
hat ja doch ich habe auch alle portale
ja immer mehr den spiegel dann so
kleinlich spiegels tillich
er kann gar nicht sein so folgt mir das
nicht das ist sehr eigenartig ehrlich
oder kann sein dass man wohin mein handy
geortet
ja ich lasse jetzt auch noch audiospur
war ich hab's nicht gehört brücke sowie
das halt macht brothers war die königin
gab keine ahnung was es war also das
ganze heute brauchen wir dann nicht mehr
ich werde gar nicht auf welchem material
ich meine meine in der first für mich
ist mein internet ist abgestürzt
rufe wieder an
ja keine ahnung ich habe schon oft
gesagt dass bei meinem internet heftig
läuft einfach nichts hallo hallo wach
moment wächst mein mann meine bambus
leitung bei der läuft die ist einfach
weg das hat in letzter zeit ein bisschen
öfters naja jetzt reden das thema jetzt
komme ich wieder drauf es regnet stellte
chaco der bewegt sich einfach nicht
westeraccum meint ihr was ist aco
genannt hier sagt sowieso malczak umwelt
aku weg dann passt es auf wenigstens
wieso follow und konform ist es auf
keinen fall eine stadt pink lassen
notfalls fliege ich dann weg aber ja das
wäre besser vielleicht ich muss
vielleicht mit muss vielleicht nein
jetzt folgt es mir alles klar
ich würde mich echt toll freuen wenn du
mir gleich helfen würde ist hier beim
haus erwarte ich hab doch wie sagt er
das war schon was kommt endlich in
unsere stadt das ja aber dann ist mir
dann in der nächsten folge weil ich
möchte in der in dieser folge und in der
nächsten folge kämpft möchte ich dieses
haus von rewe abreißen und halt mein
haus auch abreißen so ist es damit ich
dann umziehen kann und damit ich mich
dann auch dem start verpasst und danach
werde ich dann eine essens dingsbums
bauen wo ich ganz viel essen reinlegen
werde was dann zu seiner aufgabe sein
wird
jetzt muss ich mal kurz schauen von
welcher stadt ich am schnellsten in die
friedensstadt komme straße statt
es gibt eine frieden statt ganze mit da
gibt's nicht statt ich sagen so ein
punkt
sollte geplant seien als friedensstadt
ich glaube es hat sich niemals etabliert
aber generell ist da auch eine stadt die
so gebaut sein kann und meine show kommt
muss sich zu reporten hallo orten sie
sich also zu der mitte habe ich keinen
spiegel ich habe nur spiegel zu
da mache ich mir jetzt ein wieso kommt
das showcar wo nicht hier schnitt pink
rein gehst du es denn jetzt wieder bei
uns all das ist fast tot
nein das darf jetzt auch nicht mehr
sagen weil dürfen nicht mehr gläsern
feiern weil das haben die brocken von
drei wie gefeiert die müssen komplett
ausgeschlossen werden komplett raus mit
dem so also jetzt was ich dir nochmal
machen möchte es ist wahr ich das mal
hier weg weil das bremer nicht es war
ein flug zauberstab
es müsste mir eigentlich folgen dürfte
kein problem sein statt gelb geht
eigentlich am schädlichsten nie habe ich
eine schöne große fläche kann ich
fliegen vortag ich glaube das ist somit
die langweiligsten folge die hier hatte
also jetzt vom form vom vom in game was
ich gerade mache ich bau einfach nur ins
haus aber bei mir ist da ich meine ich
habe nichts gemacht
aber videos geguckt die einmal erteilte
des videos parallel ich baue nun aus
afrika ich mache gerne übrigen habe ich
für diese folge mal den drei ausgewählte
empfänger eingestellt chaco der muss
ihnen die herzen haben damit jetzt
herzen gemacht ja dann müsste er auch
kommen wieder völlig dann hängt gleich
stets via internet abbilden
sein eigentlich ja ja klar dass du hörst
aber das so fein händler kann doch nicht
sein weil ich habe heute bei 1 und alt
angerufen sagt wir haben ein handy also
samsung galaxy s 4g her geholt das stört
dauert ab geht mir voll auf die eier und
ja dann natürlich freundlich nur blabla
und hab dann lesen sogar die nummer von
ihrem akku vor hatte war ist hat dann
immer so immens hoch gefahren ist mir
hängen geblieben solange ich anhabe
verdammt alte akkus richtig aufgeblüht
er war so war schon richtig dick
und dann habe ich so gedacht wieso hat
sich anders sein
ich habe hier sogar heute noch bei
whatsapp grad geschrieben um 19 uhr
aufnahmen einer halben stunde obwohl wir
eigentlich um 19 oder wir wollen ja
nicht um 19 uhr aufnehmen aber ich habe
dem 19 uhr geschrieben aufnahme einer
halben stunde weil danach ich mir selber
mal genau was zu essen wenn das jetzt
alles steht aber du hast halt nicht
geantwortet deswegen jetzt sagen ich
weiß schon ob handy auch nicht mehr
erreichbar für eine woche und zwar weil
ich jetzt die muslimin akku herausnehmen
und zwar handelt es sich dabei um einen
produktionsfehler bei samsung selbst bei
so einer bestimmten reihe kann auch mal
kurz den akku vorlesen
falls jemand das gleiche also da unten
hier den akku also eines tages waren die
kamera jetzt dann sieht man auch habe er
sieht nicht schön dick geworden sie
wahrlich glück aber man sieht der ist
hier bisher in chicago ist so overmann
so seitdem wissen cook dann sieht man
nach unten so ein gebäude auf der
anderen seite auch das heißt er ist ein
bisschen dick und passt nicht mehr
richtig ins handy während herbst akku
sehen wollt dann guckt genau wenn ihr
unten
eine zahl hatte steht ja so ne sn das
ist die seriennummer d d1 d1e akku beim
samt und galaxy s 4 d d1 d1e so anfängt
dann müsst ihr unbedingt einen anruf
anbieter direkt anrufen
der leistet euch weiter zu samsung und
direkt einen neuen akku zu geschickt
weil der wirt für das später sich auch
bill neue handy kaputt machen weil wenn
ich den jetzt wieder ans handy zurück
tun würde
und wer sich weiter aufbläht dann blickt
er sich so auf weil es ist ja fest da
verschlossenheit alles nur und dann
würde der sinn so fällt auf plänen dass
der einfach mal die platine vom handy
weg springt so also wegreißt oha das
geil dann war ich über eine woche machen
nix sind dann ein käfer hast du ein
feuerzeug
aber ich glaub ich hab kreml noch da ich
hab seit ich habe jetzt schneiden das
irgendwie damit folgen der schaut immer
noch nicht mehr obwohl jetzt die
herzchen gezeigt hat ich bin jetzt in
ich finde jetzt einfach die oberste
etage von
rewitz haus an weil das ist heute mit
wenig machen
marc platt weil ich muss jetzt mal was
anderes machen
ich will jetzt auch nicht mit dem
zauberstab rumfliegen dass das problem
wie du willst ihm den zauberstab
rumfliegen ja nicht mit dem flugzeug
stammt nach hause kriegen oder eben der
regen macht das alles weg scheiße wir
können auch schlafen und luchs genommen
und an die folge so zuende sich gerade
noch einen schuss vor das bin ich dann
lasst auch ihren pennen gehn und dann
die folge beenden das ganze auch in der
nächsten folge macht mit dem thomas setz
dich kommt dann steht es doch dann macht
das in der nächsten folge dass wir jetzt
eben pennen gehn und tobago die erste
sondern die folge beenden nicht so ist
es ich glaube mich aus leute dann sie
bei uns absolut sexy könig gerade du
sollst schlafen gehen erstmal kämpft
sollte schlafen gehen
ja ich muss mich ausleihen deswegen war
ich dabei die folgen zehn leute die
sehen uns bei der nächsten wahl bleibt
keiner macht du bist an die pillen
wirkung lässt nach